and oh geez yeah what's really awesome
really awful
what what in God's name just happened
[Music]
Hey
hi buddy hi thanks for coming on my my
pad yeah I'm here to show you a cartoon
today I don't know if you knew why I had
you come by but now this was all
scheduled fairly outside of you welcome
to my house though you're very quiet and
weird
sup buddy it's a cartoon I'm showing you
today it's called dizzy day dizzy day
and I just just give you one the guy who
made it said that Disney is the Tiffany
of cartoons and I'm the Woolworths Jesus
so he's talking himself up big time
because obviously Woolworths
Tiffany's right yeah I think that's how
everyone I got a guy that works back
there when I yell roll them it's my wife
sure
dizzi day I told you I nailed it but
there's gonna be a horse can you tell me
what that is terrible animation yeah
it's just at first I couldn't I thought
it was like a dolly frog it's a good guy
it's a guy in a rock Sun's up animation
gets worse areas yeah it's a front ok
the front all right Birds sure rooster
on top of the everybody comes out sure
it's a classic day there started a day
all day at the place and then comes the
soldiers ok yeah who obviously that's
how they travel they're all really fat
yeah or pregnant well those are private
politicians is that guy took off yeah
they stress - actually pretty good bit
for back not really now he's on duty
[Music]
now we own initially don't we yeah
someone is in trouble
yeah and eunuch he gets his horse out of
the horse box off they go
horses back is a real pain yeah I mean
that's a that's around the drum gunner
can still hear it obviously got to get
across the river this is how you do it
back in the day no way a horse's penis
is fitting on that and the way they go
interesting seahorse yeah yeah gotta see
how you get pregnant
and then they're up she's still
screaming for help they obviously got a
change right you know and it look
foolish get that horse naked again
what's that in there he goes oh great
there she is Jesus he's gotta sighs yell
help well maybe you'd see if it was in
danger she needs help get in there and
oh jeez yeah what's really awesome
right no really awful what what in
goddamn just happened no wait hey wait
hey can we go back to the crime that
just happened so it's like hey where are
they going
mission not accomplished the yeah
so he took care of the Charlie Sheen's
he so he stopped he stopped the issue
which was a woman yelling for help so
that's yeah I got to see unexpected it's
definitely a twist now this part seems
this part seem scary to get some closure
on the crime that just took place
usually this is pretty anticlimactic I
feel like surely we will revisit the
rationale behind of the lady oh god now
I don't want too many near anyone else
sleeping baby my baby is thank God
where's my diaper party that's a man in
a find his wife and beat her up sir wow
[Music]
this guy needs to absolutely be
discharged from whatever army this is
why people don't have one respectful so
what no he's just like it an aristocrat
jail he's guarding the wall of the
village Trump's wall
horse time knock that lady out Tim time
to bunch of lady when you punch that
woman and that was it that's where he
keeps his hamburgers notes on the sax
where he keeps his hamburgers any worry
like hey two things one
he shouldn't keep his hamburger in a
feed bag to where again we're gonna push
back on him knocking that lady out I'm
sorry I'm distracted by the shorts on
this guy I mean now it's just a bad acid
trip don't you do that Trainspotting
don't you none of that was necessary
I do not be over I'm sorry I still can't
get over our earlier moment oh you want
he punched a woman why do so and it's
that house he went through all that just
to go hit her yeah look he's not he's
just killing birds oh my god or no what
is he doing he's okay the bird has a gun
so this is America 2020 whoo Bert bird
shot the horse is that horse gushing
blood
I don't think that actually does
anything so in other words just drinking
its blood
I maybe it was spit well thanks I ever
solved the problem world we're back to
cats oh wait we were never on cats now
as well it might be girl cats whoa
finally some just a boomerang it better
be that lady from earlier Jesus got it
what's he doing I mean this was made by
a psychopath like imagine let's say you
leave an animator to go make this and
you come in to check up on the progress
and he shows you this ahead let's get
the cat in the bag oh great ending it's
not an ending
and no no no yeah it's gonna kill a
caste guy better not be I mean to be
fair this is pretty true to like some
militant military situations yes true
final justice in the world
yeah I hope a lake shark gets oh you
know it's gonna come as that sea horse
I knew it yeah hello Oh doesn't help
good what in the just happened
okay I mean I'm not doing these anymore
[Music]